الياس كرام ينضم الينا من تل ابيب الياس
هذا ما يحدث اذا القسام تريد ان تقول انها
ما زالت قادره على ان تقصف ت
الابي بالفعل عثمان وواضح من هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه بانها كانت واسعه النطاق على
اعتبار ان سافرات الانذار قد جوت في
مناطقه واسعه جدا وكاننا في ايام الحرب
الاولى
صافرات الانذار امتدت من كل ما يعرف
بالسهل الداخلي وهو السهل الممتد من
عسقلان شمالا حتى
مدينه ازدو وكذلك المناطق الشرقيه لتلي
ابيب مدينه تل ابيب ايضا دوت فيها سافرات
الانذار بالاضافه الى المدن الاسرائيليه
الكبرى الواقعه الى الجنوب منها والى
الشرق منها وصولا حتى مطار بن جريون
الدولي وكانت هنالك بعض الاعتراضات
الصاروخيه عثمان فوق المدينه فوق مدينه
تلي ابيب بالاضافه الى سقوط احد الصواريخ
كما يبدو في جهه البحر لان الانفجار كان
قويا و مدويا لكن واضح بان خريطه الخريطه
التفاعليه للانذارات الاسرائيليه قد
اصطبغت باللون الاحمر في كل وسط اسرائيل
بما فيها مدينتي الرمله واللود وريش لسون
وحول وتل ابيب وغيرها العشرات من المدن
الاسرائيليه الكبرى
والصغيره كانت هنالك على الاقل ثلاث
اعتراضات في سماء مدينه تلي ابيب الان
الشرطه الاسرائيليه تقول في اخر بيان لها
بانها تقوم بعمليه تنشيط واسعه في ارجاء
مختلفه من انحاء مدينه تلي ابيب وكذلك
الضواحي التي جرت فيها عمليه الاعتراض
بحثا عن ربما شضايا صواريخ قد تكون سقطت
في اماكن ماهوله على اعتبار ان هذه
الاعتراضات الصاروخيه عثمان تمت فوق مناطق
حضاريه فوق المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى وفي
كثير من الاحيان هذه الشطايا تسقط على
مبان وتحلك فيها دمارا كبيرا بالاضافه الى
سقوطها احيانا على السيارات المركونه
واشتعال النيران فيها لذلك الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى خبراء المتفجرات
يصلون الى هذه المواق
ويقومون بمعالجتها واغلاقها ومنع
الاسرائيليين من الاقتراب منها ايضا
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي في الدقائق الاخيره
وفي اخر بيان له يشير بانه لم يتلقى حتى
الان اي اداءات استغاثه حول وجود مصابين
في هذه الاطلاقات الصاروخيه التي جاءت من
داخل قطاع غزه والتقديرات على الاقل في
الاعلام الاسرائيلي المبنيه كما يبدو على
جهات امنيه اسرائيليه تشير الى ان هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه التي استهدفت مدينه تل
قاريب جاءت من المناطق الجنوبيه ل قطاع
غزه وهذا يدلل على ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
ما زالت قادره في عمر هذه المواجهه على
تسديد هذه الضربات الصاروخيه الى مدينه تل
ابيب الكبرى رغم كل الضغط العسكري الذي
تمارسه القوات الاسرائيليه في داخل قطاع
غزه سواء كان ذلك القوات البريه سواء كان
ذلك المدفعيه التي تضرب بكثافه على مدار
الساعه وعلى مدار الدقيقه لكل المناطق في
قطاع غزه والغارات الجويه العنيفه التي لا
لا تتوقف لكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت
تبدي هذه القدرات الصاروخيه و طبعا تحديد
المكان وتحديد الزمان عثمان وتحديد
المديات واضح بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت تتحكم به هذه المحاور الثلاثه في
اطار عمليه اطلاق الصواريخ ونرى بانها
احيانا توجه ضرباتها وتركزها نحو منطقه
غلاف غزه باستهداف الحشود العسكريه
الاسرائيليه كما تقول بيانات الفصائل
الفلسطينيه المقاومه واحيانا هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه تصل الى مدينه تلي ابيل وتصل
حتى الى الجبال الغربيه لمدينه القدس كما
حصل في نهايه الاسبوع ال الماضي اذا ضربه
صاروخيه جديده تستهدف مدينه تل ابيب
الكبرى
وهذه الضربه تاتي في هذا اليوم ال74 لل
الحرب وكاننا حقيقه عثمان في اليوم الاول
للحرب من حيث الضربه الصاروخيه الكبيره
والمناطق الواسعه ايضا التي دوت فيها
صافرات القار والتي ادخلت اكثر من 3
ملايين اسرائيلي ان لم يكن اكثر في الى
الملاجئ والى ال الاماكن المحصنه والمحميه
اثر هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه التي طالت هذه
المدينه الكبرى في وسط اسرائيل وصافرات
الانذار حقيقه عثمان دوت في مناطق واسعه
جدا واسعه جدا من السهل الداخلي مدن كبرى
في واقعه الى الشرق من عسقلان واسدود بعد
ذلك شمالا في البواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه تلي
ابيب حولون وريش لسيون هذه المدن التي
تعرضت في اكثر من قصف صاروخي في عمر هذه
المواجهه وطبعا هذا بطبيعه الحال يثير
كثير من الحيره وكثير من التساؤلات لدى
الاعلام الاسرائيلي ولدى الخبراء
العسكريين الذين تجري استضافتهم في
الاستديوهات التحليليه الذين يتساءلون عما
يفعله الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا ما في وقت ما
زالت فيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على
توجيه ضربات صاروخيه الى مدينه تلي ابيب
ال الكبرى يتساءلون عن ذلك ويناقشون هذه
المساله ويخلصون الى القول بان حركه حماس
لم تستسلم بعد المقاومه لم ترفع ايديها
يقولون بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه لم ترفع
الرايه البيضاء حتى الان وهي مازالت تتمتع
بهذه القدره الصاروخيه العسكريه على توجيه
هذه الضربات للمدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى
وتحديدا تلبيب التي تشكل رمزا
بالنسبه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
توجيه الضربات لها وهي تشكل ايضا رمزا
بالنسبه لاسرائيل على اعتبار بانها القلب
الاقتصادي الناد لاسرائيل وان هو ربما
المنطقه التي يعيش فيها اكبر عدد من
الاسرائيليين طبعا تلبيب وتل ابيب الكبرى
وضواحيها هذه المنطقه التي يعيش فيها اكبر
عدد من الاسرائيليين في داخل اسرائيل
وبالتالي هذه الضربه الان لمدينه تلي ابيب
رغم العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
المتواصله على مدى اكثر من شهرين اي يعني
تثير حقيقه كثير من التعجب وكثير من
التساؤلات في الاوساط الاسرائيليه وتتساءل
عن جدوى هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه وعدم
قدرتها حتى هذه الساعه على اخماد هذه
الضربات الصاروخيه وعلى النيل من القدرات
الصاروخيه التابعه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وكثير من ال من من
الضباط الاسرائيليين الكبار الذين يجلسون
في الاستديوهات التحليليه يتسائلون
ويطرحون هذا التساؤل ويقولون كل هذه
الجهود العسكريه وكل ما وضعته اسرائيل من
قوات وقدرات وقدره تكنولوجيه لم تنجح حتى
الان في ان تدفع المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى
رفع الرايه البيض